welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer theory
undecidable problems
so one question we might ask ourselves
is are there limits to
what we can actually use a computer
program to compute and the answer is yes
some problems are undecidable and we
cannot
write a computer program that can solve
these problems
one famous example of an undecidable
problem is a halting problem
now one thing that we often use when
we're developing computer programs is
we use computer programs to help us
write computer programs so
you kind of think of like if you use an
editor with syntax highlighting
um what we're doing is we're taking the
computer program that you're writing
and we are using a second computer
program that is analyzing that program
and figuring out
uh how to do the syntax highlighting on
it so
similarly a compiler analyzes computer
programs it determines that they follow
the rules
of that computer programming language so
one question
is you know it would be pretty useful if
we could write a program that determines
whether or not a program will actually
stop
running for a given input um so
you know if i write a program can i say
hey
if i have the following types of inputs
will i ever run into a situation where
i accidentally have an infinite loop
can i analyze the program and determine
that this situation will never occur
and so that's the halting problem
so we're going to prove that you can't
actually write a program that will
be able to determine whether a program
halts for a given input
and we're going to prove that this does
not exist
by contradiction so the way these proofs
by contradiction works is
we're going to assume that the solution
to this problem
actually does exist and then at some
point we're going to see that there's a
contradiction
and that our original premise that the
program existed
must in fact be false so okay so here's
our little program here that
does actually work or we're claiming it
works we're claiming it could exist
so you can see that our program takes a
couple inputs one of the inputs is
the program that we want to analyze
and the second input is the data that i
want to run
on that program which we're analyzing
and so i
tell the program the halting program
hey here's a program i want you to
analyze and here's some data
that i want to feed to that program can
you look this over and tell me whether
or not this program's actually going to
stop for this input
and so this should output true or false
so i'm going to claim that this program
does exist
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to modify this program by
you know adding a little bit of extra
code here so i'm going to say
if that original program which tests for
halting returns
true i'm going to send the program into
an infinite loop so i mean that's easy
enough
you know it's just like while true go do
nothing and that's an infinite loop
right there okay so
uh if if that original program testing
for halting returns true go into an
infinite loop
otherwise if that program that
determines whether or not
the input will will halt for given
data input then i'm going to go ahead
and stop
now what happens when we run the program
on itself
so i'm going to go ahead and take my
extended
halting program with the extra infinite
loop test on it
as input
so that's the program we want to analyze
and then i'm going to
say i'm going to ask that program to
analyze and then
as the data i expect that program to
analyze i'm also going to use the exact
same program i'm going to say
i was going to analyze this
halting program with the infinite loop
added to it as
as data and then we're going to go ahead
and carry out this analysis so
let's look at what happens here if the
original
analysis program concludes that the
extended halting program halts on its
own code
then that original program is going to
return true because it says oh this will
in fact halt
but then we added in that extra code
that tosses it into an infinite loop
so that's kind of a problem because
we just said that it was supposed to
stop
but in fact it's entering an infinite
loop
on the other hand if uh
the halting program original analysis
program concludes that the extended
program does not halt on its own code
then that inner original test program
returns
false and this extra code we added says
if it returns true going to if we loop
otherwise
if it doesn't return true stop and so in
fact the program
stops but our analysis concluded that
um in fact
the program doesn't halt it goes into
infinite loop so
you can see we've got a contradiction
here either
we're wrong because it goes an infinite
loop or
we're wrong because it halts either way
our halting program
analysis original holding program
analysis is not working
and so therefore we can see that we
cannot in fact write a halting program
so this is just uh probably the most
famous example of an
undecidable program but the main reason
why i wanted to cover this was just to
you know sort of emphasize that i'm sad
to report
that computers cannot do everything
and that actually seems like a good
place to end our lecture
so i hope you all enjoyed the class
and you all learned a lot good luck with
your future endeavors
you